choisir entre le pays et le cas où le
parti québécois un message daniel jour 5
de la campagne électorale ou l'art de
faire passer des messages subliminaux
à peine descendue de l'autobus
philippe couillard doit tester ses
réflexes jouer avec lyon
than qui un peu à la manière de melania
utilise ses vêtements pour faire
réfléchir
oh non c'est encore lundi proclame son
t-shirt avec un panda au milieu
d'ailleurs il sera question des ours de
saint félicien le parcours pour les ours
je me sens un peu concerné quand elle
sort comme le chef libéral françois
legault par les familles lui aussi
devant une aire de jeu bien vide qui se
remplit comme par enchantement très
quand un côté solidaire
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on attend au fait on est en
train de permettre une de vos collègues
de s'installer
on est comme ça nous on est solidaire
l'occasion de faire un peu de
sophrologie jean françois lisée lui
poursuit son entreprise de libération on
a commencé par libérer vous des lâches
ensuite on ne fait libérer vous du
matériel scolaire et aujourd'hui on dit
libérez-vous des embouteillages
libérez-vous de libérez vous deux ça me
fait penser à quelque chose
le directeur si mathieu prost radio
canada montréal